california transita hacia una política
más amable con el planeta la junta de
recursos atmosféricos del estado votó el
jueves a favor de adoptar una ambiciosa
normativa que obligue a todos los
vehículos que se compren en el estado a
partir de 2035 que sean eléctricos o
híbridos
seremos la primera jurisdicción del
mundo en exigir que todos los vehículos
nuevos que se vendan sean de
combustibles alternativos y aquí porque
es significativo además de ser un cambio
de reglas en términos de nuestro
liderazgo climático y energético
esta medida que todavía necesita la
aprobación federal confiere al estado
más poblado de estados unidos- la
normativa más estricta del mundo para la
transición a los automóviles eléctricos
pues establece condicionantes para
aumentar las ventas de este tipo de
automóviles en los próximos 13 años y pp
con la eliminación progresiva de las
nuevas ventas de vehículos con motor de
combustión interna este podría ser el
último conjunto de normas de emisiones
contaminantes de grandes dimensiones
para los nuevos vehículos ligeros
convencionales la primera meta llegaría
en 2026 cuando un tercio de todos los
autos vendidos deberían ser de cero
los fabricantes de esta industria
podrían ser multados con hasta 20 mil
dólares por cada vehículo que no alcance
el objetivo esto no obstante genera
dudas en el sector por posibles
problemas en la cadena de suministros y
el elevado coste de los materiales
sound sport creo que los tres mayores
retos para la adopción son en primer
lugar la sensibilidad a la
disponibilidad y la infraestructura
desde el punto de vista de la
accesibilidad los vehículos eléctricos
suelen ser más caros y desde luego no
queremos dejar fuera del mercado los
compradores de bajos ingresos bayer
sauret market en el primer trimestre de
2022 el 16 por ciento de los automóviles
vendidos en california ya son eléctricos
pero todavía está lejos de la meta de
reducir sus emisiones a la mitad para